Dying onscreen poses a unique challenge for
an actor, but some are more accustomed to
it than others. In fact, some stars seem like
they die during just about every movie they're
in. Grab a shovel and join us for a look at
a few of Hollywood's finest fake dead people.
Spoilers ahead! Also, some not-very-pleasant-looking
movie massacres.
Samuel L. Jackson
For a guy who's made an excellent living playing
imposing characters, Samuel L. Jackson seems
to meet his maker in the movies on a surprisingly
regular basis. This has more than a little
to do with the law of averages. Simply put,
when you make over 100 films, you're bound
to be called upon for your share of death
scenes. But Jackson's many movie deaths—over
20 in all, and still growing—include some
of modern cinema's most memorable character
exits, like in Goodfellas, Jurassic Park,
and True Romance. But our favorites? There's
the time he was suddenly slaughtered by a
shark in Deep Blue Sea:
"Aaahhhhh!"
And sent plummeting to his death by evil Emperor
Palpatine in Revenge of the Sith.
"Aaaahhh!"
Gary Busey
Character actor and real-life character Gary
Busey has died onscreen more than 20 times,
and we're pretty sure he's the only actor
to be killed for the cameras by Dolly Parton,
Ice-T, and Snoop Dogg. Other memorable offings
have come courtesy of his roles in Lethal
Weapon, Predator 2, and Point Break.
Lance Henriksen
One of the most prolific murder victims in
movie history, Lance Henriksen has had the
honor of being offed by some pretty heavy
hitters. He died in The Terminator, Aliens,
and Alien vs. Predator, as well as one of
the many Hellraiser sequels. It's hard to
pick a favorite from Henriksen's list of more
than 30 deaths, but ours might be the barely
remembered Jean-Claude Van Damme movie Hard
Target, in which Henriksen's character has
a grenade shoved down his pants.
John Hurt
Obviously, plenty of esteemed actors have
bit the big one in multiple movies, but John
Hurt takes cinematic corpsehood to another
level. Not only has he compiled more screen
deaths than arguably any other actor—over
40 in all, including Contact, Hellboy, and
V for Vendetta—but the Oscar-nominated legend
also boasts one of the most memorable exits
of all-time: he was the first victim of a
"chestburster" in Alien, suffering a gory
demise that's made millions of moviegoers
jump screaming out of their seats:
(screams)
Sean Bean
Sean Bean's tendency for playing doomed characters
is so well-known that it's inspired its own
website, countless memes, and a number of
in-depth analytical studies to determine whether
he has, in fact, died onscreen more than any
other actor. We'll leave that to the number-crunchers.
Suffice it to say we've watched Bean pass
away more times than we, or he, can count,
like in Goldeneye, Patriot Games, and, of
course, Game of Thrones.
He said to the Daily Mail:
"Maybe it's the quality of my death people
are fascinated by. I liked Lord of the Rings."
Nicolas Cage
In real life, we suspect Nicolas Cage might
be immortal, but at the movies, he's uncommonly
susceptible to memorably messy deaths. He
took a stake through the chest in Vampire's
Kiss, drank himself to death in Leaving Las
Vegas, was burned to a crisp in Kick-Ass,
just to name a few. But no matter how many
times he dies onscreen, our favorite will
always be the insane way he perishes in the
all-around crazy 2006 remake of The Wicker
Man. Before that movie came along, we'd never
have guessed we needed to see Cage punch a
woman while wearing a bear suit, or watch
him howl in over-the-top agony while having
his face covered with bees:
"Aaahhhh! Aaahhh!"
Now that we've seen it, our lives will never
be the same.
Johnny Depp
Johnny Depp's distinguished career includes
over a dozen "killer" moments, including his
electrocution at the hands of Charlize Theron
in The Astronaut's Wife, and being eaten by
the Kraken in Pirates of the Caribbean: Dead
Man's Chest. His best movie death, however,
will probably always be his first: in the
original Nightmare on Elm Street, Depp's character
is yoinked down into his bed after falling
asleep, sending a gushing fountain blood spraying
up into the room after he's gone.
Even in a franchise known for its spectacular
death scenes, it remains a standout.
Michael Biehn
After awhile, it got to the point where as
soon as you saw Michael Biehn's face on screen,
you started counting down the minutes until
his inevitable death. He's arguably the most
important victim in The Terminator, he's imploded
in The Abyss, and he's shot in the forehead
by Val Kilmer in Tombstone…and those are
just the R.I.P. highlights from his first
10 years in the movies. He's gone on to the
great beyond more than 20 times, but our favorite
might be the crowbar to the head he took in
Stiletto, a little-seen 2008 effort featuring
Castle star Stana Katic.
Danny Trejo
Danny Trejo seems like one of the few Hollywood
stars who could legitimately handle himself
in a violent life-or-death situation, but
he's been on the losing end in more than a
few mortal movie conflicts during his career.
Early on, he was often called on as cannon
fodder in action films, dying at the hands
of Charles Bronson in Death Wish IV and being
blown up in the Gary Busey flick Bulletproof,
but he's graduated to more exotic deaths in
more recent years. Some of Trejo's more memorable
exits include his grisly demise in Predators.
But for us, his best death scene will always
be the poignant mercy killing courtesy of
Robert De Niro in Michael Mann's classic 1995
action thriller Heat.
Bruce Willis
Never mind Die Hard. For much of his career,
Bruce Willis' mantra seems to have been "die
often." His dozen-plus on-screen deaths have
included crucial turning points in movies
like Twelve Monkeys and The Jackal, and it
was his character who had the honor of saving
the planet by being blown up on an asteroid
in Armageddon. He's also had a couple of really
stylish deaths courtesy of Robert Rodriguez
and Quentin Tarantino, biting the dust in
Sin City and Grindhouse. His greatest death
might be his most mind-blowing: namely, the
sneaky way he bit the dust in The Sixth Sense:
"I see dead people"
But when he dies as a result of a time paradox
in the 2012 sci-fi classic, Looper? That one
might be our favorite.
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the one
you just saw. And leave us a comment to let
us know which other actors should've made
the list...